[Musique]
c'est madame j'habite rosemary 66 ans et
je suis famille d'accueil bientôt 17 ans
j'ai la passion la passion de de faire
ce travail parce que j'ai vécu avec mes
parents et mes parents ils sont décédés
avec moi ils habitaient dans la même
maison et après la mort de ma mère donc
j'ai dit j'ai dit à mon mari que si je
pouvais trouver quelqu'un pour continuer
ce travail que je fais avec mes avec mes
parents et ben j'aurais été content et
je crois que le ciel va écouter
mais la patience parce que si dans ce
métier si on n'a pas la patience on ne
le fait pas parce que si on n'a pas la
patience sera pas là moi et on n'est pas
dévoué ces trois choses qui me climat
qui marchent ensemble je dirais et
surtout de la compresse dans la
tendresse dans les gestes parce que ça
fait du bien des fois quand on entend
une vieille personne vous dire voilà mon
rayon de soleil qui arrive ou bien quand
on fait des gestes de soins quand on met
la peau mal par exemple sur le visage
d'une mamie elle vous du monde écoute ça
fait longtemps que je n'ai pas eu une
caresse et pourtant ce n'est que des
soins moi je crois que ça lui a fait du
bien j'ai je donne mais je crois que je
reçois plus que je donne
[Musique]
dette de voir un show ces gens là un peu
plus épanouie d'avoir des personnes qui
peut continuer à donner de la tendresse
de l'amour parce qu'ils n'ont pas besoin
de rongeurs de que de la moins que de la
tendresse et de l'attention et surtout
être à l'écouté est à l'écouté de ces
gens là j'avais pas sourire je resterai
[Musique]